[Music]
hey I want to thank y'all for coming to
my video I'm going dance and turn up hey
guys just loosen up a bit
[Music]
that was much worse
just relax this is my robot so just
you're not even blinking my boy a man
that you could dance a little sexier
again
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Arlene Gooden Tippin
[Music]
[Music]
what does the essay oh yeah
[Music]
waiter can I get another cookie mine's
weird nicely not blink
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so do you have any more
questions for me well yeah I heard that
you actually did a bunch of the
celebrities and can you tell me which
ones I can't really talk about things
like that
Oh got it what are you winking no reason
what do you keep doing that because I
get that you can't talk about other
patients I don't know what this is
supposed to mean it doesn't mean
anything can you please stop doing that
do you much I'm not gonna confirm or
deny anything oh of course not
oh yeah oh my god I think it's stuck oh
oh great I'm starving here yeah I am
here but I'm actually give a lot you
lost
hey you're building super confusing
really not oh I see you just walk
forward straight straight no no what are
you doing no no yes yes yes yes no no no
no stop well past the pool past the pool
yes no all right get up get up
I can't do this
[Music]
[Music]
What's Wrong Amanda my lover has left me
again I know what would you do nothing
you know guys they're all like you
drinking yes did you talk to Alice no
Amanda you know I'm never drinking again
what are you doing tonight
going out with who my girls you know did
you just call one of them
yeah and hung up on me why would you
call him because I'm sober now and I
wanted him to make sure that he
understood that we're done you don't
never learn no that's uncle basically
juice
[Music]